Islam net is raising funds to establish
a Masjid and Community Center in Norway
and they urgently need your support this
donation will be a for you because every
person that comes a step closer to Allah
through your donation you will in be
reing click the link and donate what you
can brothers and sisters and dear
friends the feel
dirt bag of this Earth is Satan calls
for a ceasefire are calls for Israel to
surrender to Kamas may Allah subh
destroy him into pieces and may Allah
allow us to see the day that happens
here's a video of his message to the
Arab
leaders
so guys as you can see Subhan Allah if
you want to keep your interests things
that benefit you remain silent now on
this matter obviously I have to be fair
in Islam to wage war to boycott not to
boycott these are and under the
obviously the decision of the rulers of
course there should be things that's
done and we know from evidence there is
clear evidence from the Quran andah
brother sisters and when there is
evidence from the Quran and Sunnah we
have no choice but to hear and submit no
matter how much we hate it the prophet
Muhammad Sall alhi wasallam did do
business with the Romans and the Jews
and the musri for that matter while
there was war outright War there were
times when he boycotted there were times
when he didn't we have we have clear
clear from the Quran and sunah for that
matter brother and sisters so but the
thing is here though the fact that he is
so boldly telling the Arab leaders to be
quiet just bolds my blood and that yes
the Arab leaders sadly sadly are quiet
this matter for God knows what can we
make those assumptions maybe can someone
choose not to I don't blame them but the
the point is what for this Satan this El
this scum of this Earth and may Allah
break his back and may Allah subh allow
us to see it his end inshallah and this
occupation and this massacre and this
genocide has taking place but as the
Arab leaders for them W brothers and
sisters it just shows you like the
prophet said nations are going to come
together and when they asked him oh
messenger of Allah why because Allah is
going to take out the fear of the fear
of your enemies that they have towards
you and going to place the love of the D
and that's exactly brother and sister
situation from our leaders to ourselves
we are too busy with our wants and our
gains and what benefits us we will go to
a Palestine protest we will miss Salah
we'll go to a Palestine protest but we
would not boycott Coca-Cola cuz we love
it you know we love it we would go and
give in donation to Palestine but we w't
sacrifice to the level where if it was
booking a holiday there's so many things
that we don't do so instead of pointing
fingers brother and sisters we need to
look internally what are we sacrificing
are we genuinely sacrificing for my
wealth are we genuinely sacrificing from
things that we want question yourself
this W question yourself this do we
really care about our brother and
sisters this is same goes for me do we
wake up at tud do we make Dua for them
sincerely do we do this may Allah
forgive us may Allah forgive the leaders
may Allah subh forgive us for not doing
enough we ask Allah W if Allah takes us
to account for this matter pertaining to
the Palestinian brothers and sisters w
we have oppressed them we haven't done
enough going to the protest is not
enough w we haven't boycotted our sins
we don't even know whated is properly we
neglect our relationship with the rights
of Allah subhana wa tala and we're here
trying to call about the rights of the
human beings the H of Allah comes before
any human being for that matter we
violate that day in Day Out so the Arab
leaders may Allah subh guide them and if
they are corrupt maaf may Allah subh
destroy them that's all we can say and
inshallah this Satan his end will come
and we will live to see
it Islam net is raising funds to
establish a Masjid and Community Center
in Norway and they urgently need your
support this donation will be a for you
because every person that comes a step
closer to Allah through your donation
you will in be reaping a reward click
the link and donate what you can